alright Latoya yes Latoya where'd you
grow up where you from what what's South
Central LA yes and tell me about your
family do you have both your parents
growing up sort of my mom was like drug
addict and yeah different me in the
house I don't know what it was
okay and how was your childhood any of
you yeah six years old my favorite that
raped me
I had one whole I'm I've returned to my
but what you're six years old - Stevie
though my snake man raped me in a head
one whole like to my vagina to my book
for two stitches at six years old walk
go to school in they made me lie - no
kids even manipulate shot mind so
remember the I say didn't take morning
it would take money to throw I tell my
mom girl they tell me but tell her that
I'm gonna joke I was a kid I believe it
you know was it so I believe what they
say without heat I believe you know and
my one had seven children with seven -
daddy
so that didn't meet you know you know
now it's price to go so when did you
leave home I twill well he molested me
already sell my breasts and when I was
telling had one big brace and what's
more it because he's something big right
one nibble
you know your mom liked was that
sticking out her sucking on it
oh great you know I just wanna like this
is a real blessing around drugs
cialis they want now I thought we good I
don't wanna [ __ ] go like that your
kids to the 18 years no one unit wins
any did you raise them get moving a lot
of Raisin Bran alone with you I don't
wanna be a race where your children in
Hawthorne Nene with them yeah they love
me well I just see like this I'm gonna
do it all my life
so was working on my life all right for
you oh no I'm gonna keep no man because
I bet all my do it I push it anybody way
it's gonna be love me you don't know how
to be loved so whenever Peter angry
everybody
ain't nobody fault so I got grew up in
your life you know but it's awkward I
don't know he talks like a deep [ __ ]
[ __ ] all right
my mom Sanders and daddy
every kid they don't make sense you know
Melissa moods you know believe me
you know your mom do you like that you
know is my mom I believe me no come on
well rotted I do definitely my mother
was about of that he's what my
grandmother was the OIC writer down here
honor
baby I said were happy to be me she did
not hesitate
she grandmother said to my brother was a
ride-or-die chick you know I love
anything she got I said what is oh she
was blind
no wouldn't realize yeah I hate my mom
did they you know you know I do take
care of me
C then we chili pepper it was never ever
lets me in see mommy she's a little
heroin and crack I mean even her kid get
wish you own it
I'm already daughter no fair as before I
acted before
so Shannon real here around people's on
and see if I mean do people without new
people people you know molested rape gay
choke kidnapped you know my damn free my
stepdad free a female vagina at 3:00
3:30 like that all right
you know I would I would destroy why you
know I'll destroy I managed to hold on I
will just fill my whole life you know in
a fall good that's right I get over he
what it's hard you know she's like
they're all I my breasts touch oh but um
we're on the whole price price too I
mean a lot of money girl I raised her
voice guys anything that we're calling
cuz I can't no I think what my breasts
Ramon go back to where I actually see I
stayed i blessing me you know it's hard
like reliving her be holding my breath
uh-huh no new guy stop
oh no jumpy gonna get my car we had a
lot of money to the next sheet I don't
do that God woo
no dude I did hurt no I'm just glad am i
doing it oh stop
you know what I got me this is real
they say you've lost a lot of money
doing that yeah I was around the car no
good yeah I know I jumped in on me no
see there's one breath
there's no game hate well I don't know
what's up you know does it my mom I said
am I missing me you know we started
using crack at what age
Oh 70-something look okay another keep
my mom yeah but I got wrong
keeping primo Hebrew my mom is
everything she's do donkeys used to be
my bottle beer in my bottle they like me
but I'll have a little beer no matter
you can be route of a baby bottle and I
feel I'd be as a craft beer that'll make
you cry for [ __ ] beer
well mom is giving me beer in a bottle
not new craft beer for beer
you know I wants a beer about it be a
little baby like Cece Ramos now I'm
gonna be tomorrow not milk beer longer
mom I'm gonna say averages so what girl
think I borrow with you I get mad
through it because it won't be it was
not beat so it's not a good mommy
yeah anger a young girl if you hook ya
dreams it you know yeah yeah like what
artist I probably chorus a dancer I did
you know like me on TV right you know
and I brought my friends that I handle
for you uh Ross he had a big house
mahuri a massive you know you know
they'll about doing my you know this
dominant I think of the dream you know
real I swear I write it I guess the
dream there's no one life okay
I've really my favorite
oh you're wise they are dreaming this
Dennis Lee they were happy I'm dreaming
this not real right now I'm watching it
right now I'm talking to you is a dream
you my dream this are real [ __ ] life
being real like this I like to call the
Rajah ha this is the dream you know when
I work about it really will be reality
you know I'm really not real isn't not
real can't be I did yoga
oh good how do you think
well these years of living this
lifestyle has changed you yeah I was
gonna say wait right no your this race
since you're young yeah I can't you
never saw another life
no no nothing books [ __ ] big [ __ ]
ass that won't crack I don't know you
need me do me
I don't know I have made my life to
survive isn't right why seven years
seventy days if my daddy my first cousin
come on my daddy's my mom my dad first
person my mother whatever says my dad my
daddy was good backing over with the
other back knows ain't one it says the
best no way
Keith you know it's another bath
that's [ __ ] up I say scary no all
right
democracy do you do what I say I'll do
we say anything you don't want you say
don't you say anything you know anything
you read my face primo and then you know
who work hard wrong
you know he's me right like I told you
call me right why the bizzy's well why
did they a hero hero do I go out the
blue you know see the exact goal um so
let's go get some bread bring money
Hey all right then come on doing it all
how your kids doing today the hot Sun in
the day and they're okay yeah okay
other day did I love me too that's fine
let's go getting that bad about the
money to me and it'll never come on I'm
faster and it's located never saw like
ain't nothing bad well my mom hey come
on
she's good like under to get my kid on
with her
never
who do you know oh let me tell my kids
doesn't impact about my mom never have
never will
you know how do we they will believe it
I think a girl has it
I was Miss Milan with is that I mean
crumble no tomorrow outside is our trend
a crushed won't do you like [ __ ] I said
it's when you sit on her ass with a fake
yeah why don't know for nothing for
nothing she hated me nothing thank you
so much for sharing your story
hey you know maybe through that I was
there
you